berkeley and i'm one of the
co-organizers of
our where our um bad math day today
i want to introduce my co-organizers who
are
chris err isabelle shankar
marielle supina foster tom and jessica
de silva so if you have a question
throughout the day today please just
message one of us over
zoom and we will get right back to you
so welcome to bad debate area discrete
math day or maybe
more affectionately called bad math day
i'm really really glad to see you all
today and i'm so happy that we can still
connect with each other over
zoom even though we can't see each other
in person
i would like to argue that it's a very
fortunate acronym
so um the silver lining of today is that
we are less bound by geography so i'd
like to thank all of you who have come
from beyond the bay area
to visit us today i'm so excited to meet
all of you
before we begin i want to thank everyone
who made
this day possible so first of all i
would like to thank the simon's
institute at uc berkeley for hosting us
today in their zoom room
and later the gather town which i will
describe a little bit
soon i would like to specifically thank
jesse and darren
who are managing all of the tech today
for us so thank you so much for making
this all possible
i would also like to thank the speakers
for sharing your work with us today
and i'd really like to thank all of you
for coming i'm so excited that you're
all here to make this community possible
so before we get started i want to get a
little bit into the logistics
so the schedule will be posted in the
chat
by one of my good friends shortly
we will be on zoom during the talks and
the coffee breaks
the talks will be recorded by the
simon's institute during the talking
portion
and then the last 10 minutes of each of
those talking times will be devoted to
questions
and the question period will not be
recorded
so i'm very excited for all of the
discussion that will happen during those
times
during the lunch break we will be using
gather town
which i think you have all received an
email from the simon's institute that
has a link from the gather time
but we will also be reposting the link
in the chat when it's time
so gather town is a website where you
can actually walk around and the science
institute has created a beautiful
reconstruction of the actual simon
institute so it'll almost be like we're
there and you can walk around
and play games and when you're near
people you can talk to them
so you can kind of mingle like you would
in real life
we will also have the gather town open
during
um after the conference so if you would
like to mingle
post 3 30 you are welcome to use the
gather town to do so
so i would like to thank all of you
again for coming
and um shortly i will introduce the
first speaker
all right i'm so excited to introduce
our first speaker today
um cat perry from the ahsoka university
of
america and she is giving a talk called
breaking symmetries
distinguishing myself skin grafts
so let's thank our first speaker thank
you so much kat
hi thank you for having me um
okay yeah i'm just gonna jump right in
um yeah so this is breaking
symmetries and graphs uh and
specifically
uh we're gonna do this by looking at a
class of graphs called
shell skin graphs that this can be done
with any graphs and that's part of why i
wanted to
talk about it today there are a lot of
open problems here
um okay and yeah so i should say that
this
uh it's kind of an ongoing collaboration
and it was started
at a women in craft theory workshop
at um the
institute for mathematics on its
applications
a couple august ago for the pandemic
um and so these are uh my co-authors so
debra
sally lauren sarah and paul
and also just so yeah i am at
soca university which is an hour uh
north of san diego in orange county so
i am not in the bay area but i am
in california
um okay
uh all right so
uh okay sorry i'm i'm playing around
with the zoom on my end to get
everyone's pictures in the right spot
but okay one thing i should say too if
you have
a question i'm fine if you just ask it
during the talk
um okay uh so
uh if i want to study symmetry in a
graph how do i
go about doing that and there are many
ways but in particular we can look at
the automorphisms
of the vertices and a graph and so we'll
say
write this as a permutation of the
vertices of g
such that the resulting graph is
isomorphic to g
and if we want to talk about how
symmetric a graph is
uh one thing we can do is we can look at
just the possible
automorphisms in g how many are there
something like that
but another way to do this
is to color the vertices
of the graph and then see
[Music]
if i want to preserve the color classes
um kind of how many vertices do i need
to color
so that the trivial automorphism is the
only one
that can do this okay and so um
yeah again many ways to study symmetry
this is one of the ways that we
investigated
and so uh yeah so i want to look at an
example so here's c8
and i want to color this with two colors
and then my question is
um if i yeah are there are there are
automorphisms that preserve the color
classes
that are not trivial
and i'm asking all of you
there's one isn't there if you kind of
flip the
flip it horizontally
uh
vertically right or about this yeah
like yeah you move it horizontally
across the vertical axis yeah exactly
okay yes
yes yeah but yeah okay and yeah and
point b there
there's one right there there is this
kind of reflection
that we can do okay so um all right
uh but what about this same thing now i
have two
orange vertices uh are there still
automorphisms that aren't trivial
you could select or rotate yeah
i can flip yeah can i rotate
if i want the two orange vertices to
remain orange
then and the blue wants to remain blue
then i think i can just
flip yes
okay okay um all right so
next question i promise i'm not just
going to ask questions the whole talk
um if i say i want to color this
with two colors and i want the
only automorphism that preserves the
orange vertices and the blue vertices
um to be the trivial one how many
more orange vertices do i need to add
or how many yeah yeah
you can add one at the four o'clock
maybe
yes perfect this one right
yeah that one yeah yeah and so right and
so
if i do this um now i have i've colored
this graph with two colors
and the only automorphism that is going
to fix the color class
is the trivial automorphism okay and so
this is what we're trying to do and then
the question is
uh here at least if i want to use two
colors
how many orange uh how many orange
vertices did i need to
use um and so okay can i could i have
done this with two orange vertices is it
just unfortunate that me putting them
together
um kind of slowed us down or do i need
three
with two you can always slip right yeah
yeah exactly yeah on this graph yeah
exactly
uh right so i do need three uh okay
new and i believe last question uh what
if i
okay so let's go back so pretend that
there are no colors here
um and i can use
i can color with any color so i don't
have to use just two i can use three
four five um what's the
minimum number of vertices that i can
have
not be blue and then i can
kind of freeze this so the only
automorphism will be the trivial one
probably two like red and green right
next to each other
perfect yeah okay i did not email you my
slides ahead of time but yeah
yeah this is exactly right um but yeah
orange and green
yeah and so if i have these
uh this coloring by having one orange
vertex and one
green vertex i am effectively fixing
those vertices in place so they are
pinned down
and i can't move them and then therefore
i can't move anything else
okay uh and so um
there are sort of two ways to do what
i'm
talking about so i can kind of say all
right let me minimize the number of
colors aka the orange vertices
how many do i need um but or instead let
me minimize
the number of vertices that are going to
not have this big
color coloring color class
all right and so um i'm going to say
that a graph
is d distinguishable if there's a
coloring of the vertices with d colors
so that only the trivial automorphism
preserves the color classes
and then we are going to prioritize
minimizing
d okay so in this case i want the orange
and blue coloring not the orange blue
and green coloring okay
so i want to say yeah i'm looking for
how many colors do i need
in order to do this and i don't care how
many get the second color
class any of that okay
and so for this uh yeah i'd say the
distinguishing number of
c8 is two because i can do this with two
colors
okay uh all right
and so uh this was introduced by
albertson and collins in 1996
and one quick observation i'll say is
that the distinguishing number is one
if and only if the graph has no symmetry
okay
and something else that is worth
pointing out too
is that different graphs with the same
automorphism group
might have different distinguishing
numbers okay so it's not
just enough to know the automorphism
group and in fact right we don't know
the automorphism group for every single
class of graphs
and here are some examples
just of kind of common classes of graphs
and
their distinguishing numbers and
something i do want to point out here is
that for
many of them the distinguishing
number is two okay and so
right away we realize that we do and
this kind of this continues with many
classes of graphs and so we do get this
sort of
large class of distinguishing number two
and so um
yes and okay so that's just this
observation and here's kind of some more
classes and so this sort of led to the
question well
within this very large class of graphs
can i
distinguish between the members of that
class
and so that led um wilfred emrich to
pose this question in response uh this
about mrs deborah one of
my co-authors defined uh what's said to
be the cost of
two distinguishing which is basically
says okay
i can do this with two colors but
what's the minimum number of vertices
that need to be in the second color
class
and so we'll say that this is the cost
of
two distinguishing and so here again
um i have this i have c8
um i know that if i color this with two
colors
then the only automorphism that
preserves the color classes is the
trivial automorphism
and like we talked about i need to color
at least three vertices
orange and so we'll say that the cost of
two distinguishing
this graph is three okay
any questions i can i know a lot of
people are jumping in the room
right now
okay um all right
and so uh one thing that's also
interesting
to point out is that as soon as we
switch to
investigating the costs a lot of times
we are
able to just find bounds okay so it's
not
like with c8 we could say okay it's too
distinguishable and the cost is three
but often times that's not the case we
you know we set this down and say okay
the cost is at least this or between
this
things like that um and so
if you get one thing from my talk i want
it to be this
there are many open problems concerning
finding the distinguishing number
or the cost of two distinguishing
various classes of graphs
and even just relaxing this parameter
looking at
uh the thing that we the second kind of
example where i had the
orange and green vertex anything related
to that there are a lot of open
questions here
okay um all right but uh what did i do
specifically or what did we do right i
had a group of people
um and so we investigated this parameter
on a class of graphs and so this is the
michelskian construction and this
was first introduced in 1955
with the goal of taking a graph k2
and then performing this construction
and
maintaining this property of being
triangle free
and then having a larger chromatic
number
okay and um
so uh that's what we
did so i will say
um yeah i think this construction is
it's a bit nasty um but it's i'll
do it with a picture but basically i'm
going to take a graph
i'm going to copy all of the vertices
and i'm going to use the first graph to
sort of dictate where the edges fall uh
in this sort of graph with twice as many
vertices and then i'm going to add a
dominating
vertex which is called the shadow master
but it's also often called the root
vertex
okay so let's say this graph on my left
is
the original graph and notice it doesn't
have to be connected and actually
uh the isolate if a graph has isolated
vertices they end up being quite
important
with this sort of thing um okay so i
take this graph
uh and then i'm gonna copy all of the
vertices
that it has and
then what i'm gonna do is so i'll use
these
to represent i'll say the original
vertices
and then each vertex has a
shadow they use will be shadow vertices
and so notice v1 is connected to v2
and so i'm going to have v1 and i'm
going to connect it to
u2 okay so the shadow of its neighbor
and similarly v2 is connected to u
to v1 so i'll connect it to u1 and i'll
just continue this process and so what
you'll notice is that
the copy the orange vertices which are
orange so that we can tell them apart
not because they have
a distinguishing coloring on them they
won't have any edges between them
okay they're just going to be have these
edges that are to sort of these original
blue vertices uh and so what you'll see
is that the degree of the original
vertices doubles
and then the degree of the shadow
vertices the orange ones is the
same as in the original graph okay
and then the last step is to add this
vertex w
of root and then w is adjacent to
all of the shadow vertices
okay so it's a lot uh
but yeah but one thing you can see i
guess hopefully yeah so remember
um the goal rate is to maintain this
property of being triangle free but sort
of by
adding in this w vertex then if i were
trying to actually vertex color this
graph
w would need a different color than what
all of these shadows have
and so that's the motivation for the
construction
okay um
all right and so formally
what's going on is it's this uh but i
will kind of spare us
all the definition since we saw the
picture
and then one thing that i do want to
point out so this is
the michelle scan of
k13 and this you can see that this graph
has a lot of symmetry right so i have
this reflection
that i can do and then
these sort of um
the leaves of the stars right here we
see them and they're kind of
they have the same neighborhood right so
they're twin vertices
and so i have automorphisms that are
exchanging them too
and it does turn out that these
michelskins of the star graphs are kind
of
worst case scenario for what we're
trying to do with
adding colors to the vertices so that
we're sort of preventing
automorphisms from being possible
okay uh but just like anything with math
right you never stop at
one one thing so you ask kind of how can
i take this further
how can i generalize this what else can
i do and so there is there are actually
multiple
sort of variations of uh this
michelle scan construction one is to
just uh take a graph
perform this construction get a new
graph perform that
perform the construction again as if
that one was the original and so on
which is what michelsky did but this is
slightly different
where instead of having just one layer
of shadows
i have as many as i want so this
superscript t is going to tell me how
many shadows i have
and again i think it is just easier to
look at a picture
and what i want to do is kind of call
everyone's attention
to this graph that's in the upper right
hand corner
which is kind of the second
um yeah iteration or i guess this
kind of uh generalized material skin
with two levels of shadows
and if you look at the orange vertices
then you'll notice they behave just like
the ones
the orange ones in the previous example
right they're kind of connected to
the neighbors uh of their original
vertex counterparts uh but then they
also
have that they have edges that go one
level below
and also one level above and that's
sort of but with the same sort of rule
dictating this
and that's the same idea right so
for the generalizations you can have as
many
layers of shadows as you want and then
their edges are just going to go
above and below okay so now instead of
having
um uh
yeah okay yeah okay questions on that
yeah so just clarification the going
from left to right
you're just adding more copies of the
original graph
instead of doubling each time is that
right
yes yeah yeah yes yes i'm adding more
copies
and then i am keeping track of sort of
what number of copy it is so like and
then
i have sort of these levels like level
one level two
level three and then the edges go up
up one and below one yeah okay good
sounds good okay perfect and then yeah
the last observation too
is that this white vertex here is the
root vertex
w and it is just adjacent to the top
level of shadow vertices okay great
okay and um all right and so
uh what did we do um and so this is we
answered a conjecture by uh
alekhanian sultani who said that
uh interestingly uh phoebe
uh that the distinguishing number of the
machelskian of a graph is less than or
equal to
the distinguishing number of that graph
okay so not the generalized michelskin
just the regular one
uh with this section of a finite number
and uh so effectively this is saying if
i do this construction then it's going
to decrease
the symmetry okay and
uh here's our result so we originally
did start with just
looking at their conjecture but then we
said oh actually there's this class of
generalize my chelsea and graphs and
it follows closely enough so we can do
it for this too
um and so yeah the thing to point out
here
is that um this tl can people see my
mouse
on here okay perfect yeah so this tl
um yes so if i have an isolated vertex
in my original graph
uh if i just perform this my chelsea
construction once like we saw
then i still just have one isolated
vertex because its shadow is connected
to the root w
but if i am doing this generalized
rachel scan
then i have a lot of isolated vertices
because they
all are isolated except for the very
last one
and so you can imagine if i have a graph
with 10 isolated vertices
to start with then this number just
explodes and so
um if i want to
put a distinguishing coloring on my
graph then all the isolated vertices
need different colors
because otherwise i have these
automorphisms where i can just switch
them very easily so
they're they're twin vertices even
though they don't have neighbors
um and so that kind of becomes a big
deal
but we can say if i don't have too many
isolated vertices then in fact their
conjecture is true
and not only is it true for um
the michelskin of a graph it's true if i
do this generalized my chelsea
construction so no matter kind of how
crazy things get
i can still take a distinguishing
coloring
from my original graph and i can
do some things and i can effectively use
it to put a distinguishing number or
distinguishing coloring
on this kind of much crazier
generalized michelle skin graph and um
okay so very quickly
um i will just i'm just gonna outline
what we did um the main thing is that
uh we kind of looked at some facts about
automorphisms what do they do
uh kind of what things are fixed and
then
we have this really nice lemma that
basically says
the star graphs are the ones that are
bad and everything else is going to at
least
fix this root vertex and so if i know
that the w
root vertex is fixed then that tells me
that the levels
of all of the shadows are fixed and then
that ended up being a big help
um and then we also had this observation
too that i'll continue
about twins from the beginning
so i can interchange twins right so they
have the same neighbors and so if i want
a distinguishing coloring then they need
to be different colors
and so yeah we just took those
observations and then we took
a coloring from the original graph and
extended it
and so um again
picture so here's my original graph
here's a shell scan if i want to do this
again
i would have even more vertices you can
see i just
they're they're kind of in this blob
right um but we can
we all know where the edges are um and
then i take this
coloring from my original graph and then
i'm just going to use as much of it as i
can
on my generalized machel scan and so
for one first i need all the isolated
vertices they just have to have
different colors
but after that i can reuse colors and so
the question
and the proof becomes is this enough
to allow me to do this and in fact it is
so i can
uh these sort of shadows of my original
isolated vertices i can give them the
same colors as in the original graph
and then actually i can do the same
thing here so
i have two orange vertices and so
if i've done this construction twice
then i'll each will have
four shadows and so i have six
vertices that are orange and so kind of
if i have an original vertex then it has
one color
um as long as it's not this star graph
originally then i can have
its shadows all have the same color and
so that's
this tactic behind the scenes and then
um
here these uh isolated vertices did sort
of
take over and were powerful enough that
that said okay
this is the number of colors i'm going
to need and then i can just do the rest
if i hadn't had them then i really could
have just taken this coloring here
and stretched it over here
um and then so then i that's how
we got our less than or equal to right
maybe it is less than maybe this wasn't
best possible but this is certainly
worse possible
um okay and
yeah and then uh okay future work
uh like we talked about right i can look
at
other classes of graphs and i can also
take distinguishing and i can look at it
with other parameters
um but also so this idea of having twins
ended up being a huge deal okay um but
what else is a huge deal um or what
other things just
whether the properties of the graph
could affect this parameter
and then also sort of relaxations
um or distinguishing colorings uh like
we saw right with more than
the minimum number of colors
um or what also what if i'm what if i'm
not just doing this with
two colors uh then can i you know what
can i do with the cost
okay thank you very much
thank you so much let's thank the
speaker